(electronic instrumental music)
- Welcome to A Conversation
With History, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Stanley Cavell,
who is Professor Emeritus
of philosophy at Harvard University.
He has taught at Harvard since 1963
where he was the Walter M.
Cabot Professor of Aesthetics
and the general theory of value.
He's the author of numerous books,
including several on film.
He's visiting Berkeley
as the Howison lecturer in philosophy.
Professor Cavell, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you, it's good to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- In Atlanta, Georgia of all places,
until the depression hit
and my father lost his
business and there we moved
to where he could find
a job with his brother
in Sacramento, California
and that didn't work
and we moved back to
Atlanta and that didn't work
Sacramento and that didn't work
and so on, but when it came
time for me to go to college
we were in Sacramento, so I
moved 90 miles down the road
and came to Berkeley.
- Uh-huh, so you come back as an alumnus?
- Indeed I do.
- Looking back how do
you think your parents
shaped your character?
- How my parents, entirely.
(laughing)
- [Harry] Give me an example,
about both your father and your mother.
- Yes.
Starting with my father, the
pervasive air of the house
was that of an immigrant
who was trying to find his
way in American culture.
He was brought to this
country when he was between 15
plus or minus one let's say.
He was not exactly sure of his age.
He had been trained as
a watchmaker very young
and he kept finding jobs, work.
It was a jewelry store that he had
that went bankrupt in the depression.
A completely unlettered man,
but in love with learning,
always spoke with an
accent which he hated,
loved eloquence, which he didn't possess
except in the form of being
able to tell yiddish jokes.
He was famous in our small
circle of acquaintances
for being able to spellbind any crowd,
especially at the dinner table,
with stories sometimes
as brief as a few seconds
with a saying sometimes
that would last 20 minutes.
Now, to tell a joke and
keep people spellbound
for 20 minutes is an important matter,
that's important talent.
I mentioned that about him
because my most influential
teacher on my life
was J.L. Austin, whose
philosophy consisted utterly
essentially in an ability
to imagine stories
that could describe and make concrete
various philosophical concepts.
So, though Austin was
completely fastidious
and an impeccable speaker of English
and my father was anything but that
they had in common this ability
to tell pertinent stories.
My mother was the artist of the family
and I think it's fair to say
great, accomplished pianist,
the best pianist in town
in that part of the states
or I didn't see any rival to her
and one of the burdens I carry
is that she gave up her career
as a concert pianist for me,
so just exactly what I was to do
with that piece of knowledge?
It's something I'm still thinking about.
- She made this known to you?
- Well yes, I would say roughly,
though she was extremely
loving, very fine,
wonderful, interesting mother,
it was clear that there was
something undone in her life.
But she was well-known,
the most prominent commercial
musician in Atlanta
since she played Vaudeville on the piano,
she was played on the radio every day.
- And she also played at silent movies?
- And silent movies, certainly.
That's a little before my time,
but I heard many stories about that.
- And what sorts of things
did you do as a family?
I get the sense from the
introduction to one of your books
that you went to movies a lot--
- We went to the films quite
religiously, twice a week.
I think probably lots of middle class,
lower middle class anyway, families did.
And in those days something
like half of the population
or more, well more, 70,
80% of the population
went to films every week and unlike now
when something like 10%
or less of the population
go to film every week.
We saw the same films, so
the web of film culture
pervaded American society in
the great Hollywood years.
- As a family did you talk about movies--
- As a family I have to say as a family
we didn't talk about movies.
The level of conversation about film
was about the same as the
level of conversation now,
which is good or bad,
thumbs up, thumbs down.
Now a lot more is known
professionally about films,
but it's still one of my sorrows
about American intellectual
life that film is treated,
though of course, at a much higher level,
and the daily journalists about film
know great deal more films
than they would have known,
they know the history of film,
but still the idea is that
what there is to say about film
you can say in a column or too.
And I wish that the advent
of film studies in the 70s
had changed that to a greater degree
than as far as I can see it has.
- Now, as a young person,
were there any books
that you read that really
affected you in a profound way
that you can recall now?
- As a young person, not particularly,
except when I read The
Count of Monte Cristo.
I assured my mother that
it was the greatest novel
that was ever written.
And then when I read Lady In Arms
I told her I had changed my mind
and that was the greatest
novel that was ever written.
Otherwise, I just read
the books around the house
and it was an unlettered
household, so it was not until
fortunately, it was not until
I went to college really
and the fortunate part was
that I went rather early
because I was somewhat precocious.
So in those days they used to
skip you, so called, grades,
an absolutely destructive custom I think.
It destroys your social life,
if not your psychological
life, both the same time,
but it meant that by the time I was 16
and showed up at Berkeley,
I was so dazzled by the
conversations that I found
going on in Berkeley, that it seems to me
that I didn't sleep for about four months.
- Now, as an undergraduate
you were torn I gather
between being a writer
and being a musician
is that a fair description of your state--
- It's a fair description,
especially of the latter
two years of my life.
In the first two years I
was completely absorbed
in the life of music,
particularly as it related
to theater at Berkeley.
Berkeley in those days had no theatre,
but it had extremely energetic
and wonderful actors and directors.
And for one reason or another
it was I who showed up
most often and was awarded the rights
to write instantal music for the theater.
So much of my first two, even three years,
as an undergraduate was
spent composing music
either for our annual reviews,
as skits and songs, or for productions.
No smaller for example,
than writing the incidental
music to King Lear.
(laughing)
- Quite ambitious--
- Reasonably ambitious.
- What years are we talking about
that you were at Berkeley by the way?
- I entered Berkeley and in '43.
Yes, and I had enough credits to graduate.
I didn't keep track of these things.
I would take six music courses
and two other courses and so on
and I just felt this was life.
I don't have any plans to
graduate or do anything else,
but by 1947 I had acquired enough credits
and distribution requirements
so that in the summer
that year I was told that I had graduated.
- Forced out (laughing)
- [Stanley] Roughly
- But you keep returning to Berkeley,
so then you must have
really liked that first--
- I have over the years, yes.
Berkeley's the place of
magic for me, still is.
- As are the movies,
we'll talk about that,
but then you went to New
York to a conservatory--
- I went to New York to...
To complete a portfolio of compositions
to apply as a composition
major at Juilliard.
I was already past the age of
the normal Juilliard student
so in the extension
division they accepted me
as a composition major
and within three months,
two months, six weeks,
I started playing hooky
from my composition lessons,
realizing that music
was not over in my life,
but the idea of spending my
life as a composer was over.
I no longer believed in what I was doing.
It isn't that I thought
it was bad particularly.
It's just it wasn't me and I
had acquired the beginnings
of an education at Berkeley
that went so far beyond music
that I was catching up
and catching my breath
and being bewildered and not
knowing what I wanted to do
and the theatre was part of that,
but taking courses in literature
was another part of it.
- And we should note that one
of the ways you played hooky
was you did what?
- Yes, you've sneaked a look at this text
where I mention that.
Right you are.
Yes, well, I went while
I was playing hooky
to at least two films a day
and often to the theater in the evening.
In those days 42nd Street in New York
was a place where you could see
the history of the last 10 years.
It was before the porno street
and before the
reconstitution of the street,
it was in the late 40s.
A place where, reruns doesn't put it,
it was slightly older than reruns,
but if you went twice a day for months
you saw an extraordinary number
of awfully interesting films
with a terrific audience too
that really appreciated these films.
And then I saw the complete
theater season of 1947
which means I would still
could see Laurette Taylor
in The Glass Menagerie,
which was still running
and I saw Marlon Brando in
A Streetcar still running
and so forth.
So I had my fill of a New York experience
as well as my sense of
playing hooky from Juilliard.
I had enough of the Juilliard experience
to know what it would have been like,
but I had wanted all my life
to go and that's what I did,
but my father being an immigrant
said first to graduate from college
then you go to conservatory.
But he wanted to see the piece of paper
that saw that I had credentials
as an educated human being.
But by then the chance
of starting all over
or starting a conservatory
career was for me
out of the question.
- So what led you to philosophy?
- Yeah, well, I could give
you a cocktail answer to that
or I could say I'm still
asking myself the question.
One way, serious way
to answer the question
is to say that leaving music
was the first enormous basic
radical crisis in my life.
I was bewildered by who I might be
if I wasn't a musician and
philosophy is after all
subject you might come
to in a state of crisis.
That's one thing that happened
to me in finding philosophy,
that I found in philosophy
something that not just answered
the sense of crisis, but
that in some way seemed to me
a continuation of what I wanted from music
in it's precision and in it's
profundity, was an accident,
I asked myself whether it was an accident.
But a third a way to answer
that is that if it's a crisis
you still have to find
representatives of philosophy
who could provide the
basis for these discoveries
and that I found at UCLA.
I went there on the promise of being hired
to write some music for films maybe,
but first you had to establish
residency requirements
of the musician's union, that took a year.
In that year I went to UCLA and I fell,
I was hooked by philosophy,
it had a wonderful philosophy department,
awfully interesting people,
and that turned out to be it.
There are more bumps in the road,
but by and large that's what happened.
- This is a silly question,
but I'll ask, what does a philosopher do?
- Of course the serious answer to that is
they ask themselves that
and almost everybody
has his or her own answer to that.
All the great philosophers
have their answer to it.
It winds up in their texts
that what they're looking for
is a definition of why their
lives have been flattened
or floored and how it came to pass
that to question themselves
was how they wanted to spend their lives.
And they question themselves
and answer themselves
in as different ways as there have been
the great names in the
history of philosophy
and I regard myself
and I regard my friends
as trying to find their
way among those names.
- And is it, you're
suggesting that in a way
that not knowing the
answers is part of the game
of philosophy, but in
fact developing a rigor
and a precision that allows you
to do the pursuit of answers
in a professional way.
- Yeah, now the issue
of professionalization
strikes another note.
So, I don't mean you didn't
deliberately strike this note,
but if you say from there
for the past 200 years
let's say philosophers have
been professors of philosophy.
Kant is the philosopher
that showed us that you can
be a professor and
produce great philosophy.
It wasn't clear before,
Descartes wasn't professor of philosophy
Locke wasn't, Hume wasn't,
Schopenhauer wasn't, Spinoza wasn't,
but you could say of them
and of their successors, either
that they attempt to produce
a system that answers the
basic questions of existence.
That system everyone will
say or something of the sort
has since the 17th century
converged on questions
of knowledge rather than
on questions of beauty
or of goodness, though every
philosopher has some view
of all of these things.
Or, philosophers can undertake
to question all efforts
to create a system of philosophy.
But in my book. the
compulsion to systematization
and the compulsion to
question systematization
are equal human drives and
so I question both of them.
- And what does it take
to be a philosopher?
If a student were watching this
what are the prerequisites
for doing this kind of work?
- Yeah, another question one
asks oneself all the time.
One sort of empirical
answer to the question
is that if you have a taste for it
and taste for it is required.
I could put that as a mood for it.
You get to a mood where
you can only be found
by making assertions and
finding yourself dissatisfied
with everything you've said.
If you like that state
of being dissatisfied
with everything you've
said or that's said to you,
you're probably hooked already
and so philosophy has chosen you.
But I was going to give you
an empirical answer to it
and that is when you go
to college for some people
philosophy can happen early.
It inevitably happens early,
but you don't recognize it.
That is questions of the sort of
what was the first thing in existence,
or what is God, or is there a best thing,
a best life for me to lead,
or what is love, and so on.
You may stay up all night
asking yourself these questions
and you may not call it philosophy.
Then when you get to college you learn
that there's a name for this.
Then if you seek out the
people who know this name
and who are talking these
things it turns out,
empirically, I say there's
not a theoretical answer,
that those are the people
whose conversations
you want most to participate in.
That is a way to discover this,
which means you need to be exposed
to these things one way or another.
That's a way to test it.
Another way to test it is
'cause we've all asked ourselves that.
When I asked my philosophy teachers
I found I ask myself
doing this day and night.
I said how do I know if
I'm really doing this
if I'm really responding in a way
that means anything to these texts
or that means anything
to anybody else but me?
And the awful and the wonderful thing is
there really is no
answer to this question.
A famous story for some
of us is that Lichtenstein
whom many of us do not
doubt was an original
and important philosopher,
asked this question of Russell:
Am I a philosopher or
am I a complete fool?
And Russell told him he
wasn't a complete fool,
but there's still a
prior question which is
why Lichtenstein asked it of this person
and why this person was
credible to him as an answer,
so you pick your shots.
- You have a large body
of work in philosophy
and in our discussion I
thought it would be useful
to talk about your work on
film, which interests me
and I think will help us sort
of talk about doing philosophy
in this particular context,
but could you tell us
what the relation of your
other work in philosophy
is to your work in film or is there one?
- Oh, I hope there are lots.
I think for sure there's not just one.
You asked me the right
question in suggesting
that if I write about film
it's for reasons that anyway,
struck me as philosophical reasons.
But the question is odd,
it's another one of these questions
that has different levels of answers
and on a different day I
might answer differently.
But my first writing about film was
well, there are various
ways to answer this.
I don't mean to stumble,
but I don't want to answer
more superficially than
I absolutely have to.
In a short time
I found myself going
to films less and less
and I wondered why that was the case.
It's true I could answer by
saying well, I didn't have time,
at Berkeley I was teaching
three courses every term
and I was trying to finish a
PhD thesis at the same time,
so of course I couldn't go.
That is not much of an
answer because for one thing
Berkeley was the best on Earth
as far as I knew to see films.
Pauline Kael had in those
days started her two,
then three venues,
small rooms in which you could see film.
It was an education.
It was another one of those
moments eventually in my life
when I finished my PhD thesis
when I went every night
again and saw two films.
Odd education, but to be
drowning in the material
is really the only way
not to care too much
what you're seeing,
to care a lot about what you
think about what you're seeing,
but to see everything you
can that's indispensable.
And I want to know why.
More basically I wasn't going
to films and I started then
out of this sense of something
missing to write about
what is this thing that I'm missing?
What did it satisfy that
nothing else satisfied?
So my first question is when
I ask myself what's film?
Philosophical question came in the form
of what's are it's differences?
And from painting, from
theatre, from any of the arts
from literature, how is a
script different from libretto,
all these questions.
And that produced this book
that I see on the table here,
The World Viewed, but when I
said I wanted to be careful
there was a moment before that,
which I believe I don't talk
about in any of these texts
that I've written that had
already given me the sense
that film meant something to me
that I wasn't able to write about
and that was while I was
working on my PhD dissertation.
After months and months of
writing day and night on that
and teaching classes, I
decided to let myself,
because I was stuck, go to a film.
And it turned out that the film
was Smiles of a Summer Night,
an Ingmar Bergman film.
But it probably was playing in
a real theater, real theater,
in a commercial theater,
and it may have been
my first my first good, not
good, my first Bergman film.
I'm not sure, I had just become
aware of the Gadar films,
the Fellini films, that
were beginning to emerge
and I was fascinated.
They started putting a perspective
on the films that I'd seen.
Everything seemed to me
undergoing change by them.
But the effect in particular
that Smiles of a Summer Night
had on me was that I went
back to my pathetic digs
and wrote about Smiles for a
Summer Night all night long
when I should have been
writing about my trying to add
a couple of pages to my dissertation,
but it wouldn't leave me alone.
And after a night of
that I had, I don't know,
some thousands of words, none
of which I ever published,
but they were the moment
at which I recognized
something that seems to me I've known
about the other arts
since before I could talk.
I could read music it
seems to me before I could
as I recall it, before I could read words
and I'd known since then
that in the arts everything matters.
This was the first time that
I had had the experience
of a film in which I had
the absolute knowledge
that everything that went
on in that film mattered.
So that what writing about it meant
was to discover why each
frame was the way it was,
why each gesture, why each
posture was the same as it was,
and why each word was
said, not just as it was,
but where it was, by whom
it was said in that light
and with that background.
And so true or false, illusion or not,
that was my experience of
what knowing a film was.
And by the time some eight
years later in another country,
I had by then moved back to Cambridge,
this sense that I wasn't going to films,
even newer films, came over me.
It was with that sense
that this is what I needed
to discover for myself.
- In one of your essays you're
talking about Buster Keaton
and you're talking about how
movies give us a capacity see
and then you say "every
motion in particular,
every human posture and
gesture however glancing
has it's poetry or you
may say it's lucidity."
And I guess that's what you're
suggesting happened to you
when you went to--
- Good, good for you, yes.
That is the sort of
experience that I was having
and what I would have
meant by saying has its own
well, the quotation, I'm not
going to say anything better
than has its own poetry...
And where to characterize that poetry
means to say something lucid.
This is an old Emersonian moment of mine.
Emerson has a crack that when
I read it I thought yeah,
that's something I want
from writing philosophy.
He says you need always to
look for the gleam of light,
the spark, the...
What else does he call it before?
Not instinct, sometimes he calls it,
but the main thing is intuition.
And the reason he says intuition
is that he wants to go on to say
for which you then go on
to provide the tuition.
So providing the tuition
for intuition I could say
that's what I would like
both philosophy to be about
and to do and it's certainly what I wanted
writing about film to do.
- You also write somewhere else,
and I didn't write the source,
but you said "I understand
philosophy is a willingness
to think not about something other than
what ordinary human beings think about,
but rather to think
undistractedly about things
that ordinary human beings
can not help thinking about."
Yes, I accept that also as philosophy.
The difference in all of
these characterizations
is that they're all to specific doubts
and specific questions about philosophy.
In a certain mood if you
ask me what philosophy is
I could answer it's to
think undistractedly
about what we can't help thinking about.
That's an answer, but it's
not an answer I would give to,
for example, why'd you write about film?
Or why'd you write
philosophically about film?
Or what's the relation of
your experience to philosophy?
How faithful do you have
to be to your experience?
Do you want to preserve your experience,
transcend your experience?
So I'm glad for these things.
I've been noticing in one of
my favorite texts in the world,
Lichtenstein's Philosophical
Investigations,
he has an endless set of remarks
about what philosophy is.
They're not endless, my old teacher Austin
would hate saying endless.
He has 47 different, I don't
know how many there are,
but there are a number
of characterization for,
each should be traced back
to some particular contratall
that he has had for
which he's asking himself
what's he doing, what's he looking for?
- Was it a matter of some
controversy that you--
- Excuse this hacking,
this has been going on
for some days, I hope you--
- No problem, but Berkeley is known for
not only it's movies and the
power of it's intellects,
but also it's allergies.
- It's allergies is it, I see.
Well, it's helping.
I'm better off than I was
three days ago, but we'll see.
- Was it a matter of
some controversy when you
a professor of philosophy at Harvard
started writing about films?
(laughing)
- It's caused me a certain
amount of grief, that's true.
But the grief, Harvard's
rather a proud place
as Berkeley is, so as Berkeley might
they figure if you're there
you probably know what you're doing.
But there was quite a
lot of curiosity about it
and I like that.
On the one hand I think
that I have wanted film
and I think it may have been a motive
that got me continuing.
I've written much more about
film that I'd ever expected to.
You point to three books of mine
I'm amazed by that,
that's probably a quarter
of what I've written.
I hadn't expected that,
but what's kept me going
was the sense that it was not a question
of why I was interested in film,
but a question of why since
everyone is interested in film,
one supposes throughout the world,
why don't philosophers write about it?
That was the question that
perhaps more than anything
puzzled, bothered, even provoked me.
And one of the things I
hoped for is that I invite
I don't say there aren't any
others, but really terribly few
in all traditions, in both
traditions of philosophy
either on the continent
of Europe or by us,
terribly few who take it really seriously.
There are in the Frankfurt
School of Philosophy
exceptions to this, but
even Walter Benjamin
always mentions, almost
obligatory to mention
in the study of film, never
wrote a critical account
of a film and he regarded
himself as having an aspiration
to become well, one of his aspirations,
the greatest critic of German literature.
but he didn't have any
aspiration to become
the greatest critic of film.
He wrote some remarkable things about it,
but not that, why not that?
And it has not become, so
I have wanted to become
a normal part of what
philosophers did in their work
in aesthetics for example,
that hasn't happened.
There are exceptions, it's happened more.
I've also wanted to become
something that was more
a part of a university curriculum
than it has managed to be.
Of course there are now departments,
but I didn't want it to
be a department exactly
any more than I want there
to be a department of books.
(laughing)
Department of film, of
course, it's not the same
and film is it's own gorgeous subject
and the making of film is
it's own gorgeous craft
and having grown up as a musician
I'm not unaware of what it
takes to really become a master
or a good apprentice or a follower
or of a devotee of these crafts.
Still, there is such a
thing as thinking about film
and it hasn't become as common a practice
and as ordinary, which I
would have liked to see,
and that maybe not something to deplore,
maybe something further to think about
if I could realize that
that's the way things are.
It's not going to happen, then it may be
that what one should ask oneself is
what is it about film that
seems inherently illicit,
not really something you do
quite in the light of day,
but something you
sneaked in to the theater
before anybody quite sees
you, or when you're too young,
or that secrets are being revealed
which you're afraid to reveal.
There is something of that shock in film.
Film is shocking.
We know it shocking in
it's aspects of horror
but maybe it's just as shocking
in it's aspects of comedy
and we don't see it.
- And you suggest in your
writings that what movies do
through the camera is to
focus on things we don't see
in the ordinary and to do
that watching in silence.
That's very important
to your theory isn't it?
- It is, the relation of what
films construct for you to see
and what we see is simply
endless and I expect there to be
further and further instruction about that
as writing about film goes on.
You can't help thinking about that.
- I wanna get a handle on why
you went through this door
and in one of your introductory essays
you say that your father always said
that you could learn
something from everybody
on the one hand.
So that that points us to
an understanding of why
you could find significance
in what appeared to be very ordinary.
But you also talk about this
American cultural tradition
which is one is which
there isn't a high culture
established in the way it is in Europe
and there is a movement
between high and low culture.
Both of these suggests to me reasons
why you went through this
door of film, is that fair?
- Yes, sure it's fair, it's fair.
I'm an American kid
and so I went to the
Saturday afternoon movies
as American kids in my day did.
And it's...
I want to answer it various
levels about this again.
That it is a feature of American culture,
that it is produced two of
the most admired and treasured
forms of art that can be called
something less than high art
but which really have served
to question the distinction
between high and low art, are,
after all, movies and jazz.
And American film has
made it's contribution
to the world art of cinema
and it has been a puzzle to me
that American intellectuals
and academics, I include among,
have not wanted to understand
and appreciate that fact.
That's one level of answer.
I don't want to say that America
has established it's
position in world cinema
more than its rights in
the high arts of the world.
Though American intellectuals in some way
don't on the whole,
treasure these matters.
Why should I say that
they don't on the whole,
some do and maybe enough
do, but it has bothered me
that it doesn't play a
role in American thinking
and not in American philosophy in the way
that I want it to or
had hoped that it would.
Speaking about that
however, is that I want it
to be matters of ordinary
conversation and illusion.
For example, in professional discourse
in a way that it really
hasn't been able to be.
If I want to refer to a
film in a lecture of mine
I have to think how likely is it
that this film has been seen
and if it's not likely, how
much of it shall I describe
in order to try to make this point.
Whereas if I want to refer
to any novel however obscure
well, not however obscure,
but to one of the great novels
of James, or Proust, or
any of hundreds of novels
and one knows we haven't all
read all of these novels,
but there's no hesitation in referring
to what happens in this novel
not because one would
be embarrassed to say
necessarily if they haven't read it.
I mean there are jokes about
who's not willing to say
they haven't finished reading Proust,
but that's not what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about whether
you're really communicating
something or not.
What's the feeling?
You say it, if you want to go look it up
and have a chance or
think about it then do.
You don't just say I
like to teach that way
as well as give public lectures that way.
I like to say something
beyond what students are apt
to have at their command,
partly to say there's a large world
go find out, partly to
say you may not have heard
of this yet, but you will and
here you can work your way
back and find something to do with it.
Film has not become easy in that way.
It isn't as though people
will feel grateful if you say
oh, you should see this and
relate it to these other things,
treat it in this way.
I'm still asking myself why not?
That is why I think again as with films,
as with music, as with
the arts, the arts differ.
You should try to see everything
as well as hear everything.
But I also think as I've
said, you should discriminate
and find out which gets to
you and then ponder why.
And I don't on the whole
find as many occasions
for that as I would like,
so I write books about it.
- And let's talk about the two major books
that you've written on film.
One is called Contesting Tears:
The Melodrama of the Unknown Woman
and the other: Pursuits of Happiness:
The Hollywood Comedy of Remarriage.
Now both of these suggest
that, the two sets of movies
that you're studying and we'll
talk about that in a second,
really are a kind of important moment
in the evolving consciousness
of women about their,
on the one hand, relationship
to men, and on the other hand
about their determination
of their own lives
and the realization that
they don't need men,
that they want to go it alone.
Talk a little about why you
chose these two sets of movies.
- We are having the same problem.
It's a question of where I dig into this.
I think I'll take it in stages
about the the more important of the text.
The more fundamental is the
book on remarriage comedy
because the melodramas I
say are derived from them.
I care about the melodramas
and it's very important
what you've just said that
there are these two to the day,
one light, one dark.
In the comedies a certain
agreement to marriage
is arrived at, it's very ambiguous.
In the melodramas, marriage
as a possible state
for these women is rejected,
but the fact that one is
derived from the other
means that these women are
connected to one another,
I call them sisters of one another,
and why one takes one path
and why another set takes
another is the subject of both,
well, especially the second book
about the comedies.
It happened to me as happened
to so many people in the 60s
that we rethought our
existence as professionals,
as teachers, as members of
universities, as Americans,
during the Vietnam War.
As a part of my incessant
conversations with students
in those days about everything,
the world opened up.
We talked about things you
would never dream having,
I wouldn't have dreamed that
I would be talking to students
about whether they should
enlist for the army,
whether they should get married,
whether they should stay
in school, endless topics.
We were going to movies again together
and I tried giving a course about films.
I wondered in my relation to the young
how the movies that I
treasured when I was young
would hold up now.
This is after I had started
thinking about the earlier book
on the ontology of film on the world view
and I had some things that I
could already say about film
but now I wondered how about
really choosing the films
that I recall as mattering to me.
So I gave a course in
which from memory I ordered
but then I thought the
test case will be comedies.
If you can share a sense of humor
then you know that the generations have,
everyone was talking about generation gap
and so on in those days,
I thought well, suppose we
could share senses of humor
that would matter to me,
so I ordered some films
that I remembered and it
turned out that the seven films
I maybe miss remember, but the bulk,
at least five of the
seven films that survived
and form the basis of
Pursuits of Happiness,
The Comedies of Remarriage,
were among those I
remembered as being the best
and most memorable of
the comedies that I saw
growing up in the 30s and in the 40s.
- And these are movies
like It Happened One Night,
Adam's Rib...
- Exactly, Bringing Up Baby,
The Philadelphia Story,
His Girl Friday, The Awful Truth.
And when we screened them, they held up.
The students were
absolutely involved in them,
absolutely ready to go through
and talk until we dropped
about what was going on in them.
This was exhilarating for me
and the more we got into them
the more fascinated I came by them
and then I had one of
those clicks in the head
in which I saw what they seemed to have,
some process they seemed to share
each in a different way
and that is the feature of
not as in classical comedy, a
young pair getting together,
fighting, obstacles to their romance
usually in the form of the woman's father,
but winning out in the end
and the comedy closing in some festival
generally called marriage,
but on the contrary
beginning with trouble,
beginning with threat of divorce
on the part of an older
pair where the narrative
is to find it's way to
getting the pair back together
or in the title of, not great,
but still a member of the genre,
getting the pair together again.
And it turns out that that one difference
turns out to have an indefinite sequence
of features that differ.
- You make the point in the book
that this is actually a coming together
or the number of factors
both in Hollywood,
the generation of actresses
that were appearing
in these movies, all leading
to a kind of rethinking
of a woman, her role in society,
in her relationship to men
which would have also been
very relevant to the times
you're talking about, the 60s,
when you were doing this writing.
- It would have been or
especially just a little bit later
when these issues more and more
occupy the center of stage.
Yes, I don't know that it was for,
it couldn't have been
exactly explicitly for me
because it was on the social agenda yet,
but there I retreat to the more personal.
I grew up with a professional
woman as a mother
and I knew then that
she was not really like
the other mothers of the friends of mine
who were at home and when I would read
that the Hollywood tearjerker were made
for isolated wet afternoons
in darkened movie theaters
I thought my mother
didn't go to the movies
in the afternoon, she was working,
so when you're talking about?
They can't have been made just for women,
so for whom were they made
and what are these films?
And it turned out that the films
that I thought were the best
were themselves preoccupied
with women of this character
who demanded equality with the men.
They demanded something
that they called marriage.
The difference between the
women who accept marriages
they find it, when in the melodramas
the women don't find it and
they won't accept anything else.
There might be other reasons
why they don't want to
be married to a man,
but one reason is they
haven't found any man
for whom it's worth it.
So what they do is resist
society's compulsion to marry.
How they find the strength to resist that
in those days is something else.
So of course it occurred to
me to ask why are the films
that I find best in the
Hollywood productions
and I'm not the only
one who finds them best,
those films, those Hollywood
comedies are beloved worldwide
and they were seen by
the directors of films
all over the world, Indian directors,
Japanese directors, Russian directors,
Chinese directors, all knew
these films, admire them,
learned from them, treasured them.
The best collection
I'm told of these films
now exists in the Soviet Union.
I don't know whether the archive
has been opened up yet or not.
I'm glad to know that there
are perfect prints available.
I hope, they need to be,
but the question why they
should be about such women
is a standing question.
They saw something in them.
Now does it have to be...
Can they only be made by
actually casting women
born between 1904 and 1911 as Irene Dunne,
Barbara Stanwyck, Katharine Hepburn,
all were or are there equivalents?
Now you know they're not
the only women of this kind,
so that's one something I take
it that you're referring to
and saying things came together then
in order to make these
films, that's right.
So a question that comes after that is
do these films continue to be made?
Well, evidently they don't
continue to be made in that form
so what does one expect of them now,
what's come together now?
I don't really know how
to answer that question.
For one thing, film doesn't
play the same cultural role
in the states.
Now, if only 10% as opposed
to 90% of the population
now goes to films every week
and they see different films
it stands to reason that
what's called a star
is a much more evanescent thing
than what a great star was
in the 30s or 40s and so on.
Not at all to say there
aren't absolutely first-rate
and wonderful fascinating films made,
but they're not made so to
speak out of the same mold
and reliably and a
certain number every year.
- So now we've come to understand
why you went to the movies
why you became a philosopher
and began going to the movies
as a philosopher and thinking
about them in that way.
But movies are a mass media,
so what I would like to ask you
is how would you distinguish
the way you respond to movies
versus the way a mass audience,
what do movies do to us
and what is the distinction to be made
about how a philosopher responses to them?
- Yeah, well, I hope to heaven
that I respond to movies
the way everybody else responds to movies,
otherwise I wouldn't trust
what I said about them.
It may be that I trust
them to be saying something
more than most people do.
It maybe then when a tune
gets stuck in my head
or an image gets stuck in my head
I figure there's a reason why
and I'm on the lookout for it
maybe more than others
do, but the impact I hope
is just a plain down and
dirty being overwhelmed impact
to talk about what that is.
Why they are overwhelming
is a part of an ongoing
aesthetic inquiry into what films are.
What it is about them that allows,
The World Viewed as I think
is much about that question
as about anything else.
It used to be that you could
say it's one of the things
about film is that the
gigantism of the images
which dwarf you, which infantilize you,
which make you speechless.
But maybe one can see smaller images now
and still have an experience of film,
but now there are so many
intricacies and technologies
involved that somebody's
going to have to rewrite
all of this for each
of these technologies.
I think there's nothing a priori
about how they transfer to one another
so when I talk about film
I'm still talking about
the screening on a big screen,
and now even what an
audience is is different
from what an audience is anywhere else.
That is I distinguish
roughly just to begin with,
one difference between
the audience of a film
and the audience in a
theater is that the theater
still feels like the assembly of a city
and in a movie you can
be simultaneously two,
you can be alone, that's
one important experience,
but you could be two
and that could be an
extremely important audience,
the two of you there,
and it can be worldwide at the same time.
So all this just has to be unraveled.
Just takes patience to figure
out what these things are
and to take individual moments.
For example, film can be,
I think it was Thomas Mann
who was convinced that
film was not an art,
various people have
been convinced that film
is not an art for
different kinds of reasons.
One is I'm repressing
his name for a moment,
very well-known writer,
mostly about silent film
an esthetician, whose idea
was it couldn't be art
because it was photography
and photography just copied the world
so that can't be on, well
that's not a very heavy reason
any longer since one doesn't
feel that photography
copies the world and so on.
But what he was responding
to may have been something
that Thomas Vaughn was
responding to that I alluded to
namely that the experience
is too overwhelming
for it to be art, it's something else.
It hits you like circus does
or like an overwhelming sports event
or an automobile accident
which Gadar almost says
in one of his films.
So that's not a response that
you could really attribute
to something that's artful or is it?
Can you make of that
something that's ponderable
something that has a sublimation
into intelligible shareable responses,
not simply isolating
responses of this kind,
but to be continued.
- On that note Professor Cavell,
I want to thank you very much--
- Well, is our time up, thank you.
- Yes, our time is up
and this has been a fascinating Odyssey
that took us both through
your work in philosophy,
but also we went to the movies.
- We did a bit go to the movies.
Well, I appreciate it,
I enjoyed it very much
and I apologize again for the sniffles.
- No, thank you, but
thank you for coming back
to Berkeley and come back again.
- [Stanley] It's a pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(electronic instrumental music)